it is still tragically sometimes assumed
that the best way to cheer someone up is
to tell them that everything will be all
right to intimate that life is
essentially a pleasant process in which
happiness is no Mirage and human
fulfillment a real possibility however
we need only read a few pages of the
book known as the posse by the great
French 17th century philosopher Blaise
Pascal to appreciate how entirely
misguided this approach must be because
Pascal pulls off the feat of being both
one of the most pessimistic figures in
Western thought and simultaneously one
of the most cheering the combination
seems typical the darkest thinkers can
paradoxically often be the ones who best
lift our mood Pascal was born in Havana
in central France in June 1623 and from
the earliest days learn to look at the
glass of life as half-empty his mother
died when he was three he had few
friends he was a hunchback and he was
always ill luckily he was recognized
from an early age and by more than just
his proud family to be a genius by 12
he'd worked out the first 32
propositions of Euclid he went on to
invent the mathematics of probability he
measured atmospheric pressure
constructed a calculating machine and
designed Paris's first omnibus then at
the age of 36 ill-health
forced him to set aside plans for
further scientific exploration and led
him to write a brilliant intensely
pessimistic series of aphorisms in
defense of Christian belief which became
known as the posse the book for which we
today chiefly remember and revere him
the purpose of the book was to convert
readers to God and Pascal felt the best
way to do this was to evoke everything
that was terrible about life having
fully considered the misery of the human
condition he assumed his readers would
then instantly turn for salvation to the
Catholic Church
unfortunately for Pascal a very few
modern readers now follow the posse
alike
this the first part of the book listing
what's wrong with life has always proved
far more popular than the second which
suggests what's so right with God
Pascal begins by telling us that earthly
happiness is an illusion but he's
especially keen to point out how much we
hate being on our own thinking and
exploring our own condition Pascal is
perhaps best known for this aphorism of
genius two lamellar art is on yong-joon
soul Shaw's hidden opacifier demoiii or
hope or dodging sharm all of man's
unhappiness comes from his inability to
stay peacefully alone in his room this
aphorism should be written in large
letters in the departure lounges of all
the world airports Pascal's charm lies
in his bitterness and [ __ ] cynicism
people will do anything rather than
consider their dreadful reality he
thinks man is so vain that the slightest
thing like pushing a ball with a
billiard cue is enough to divert him at
the same time for Pascal people are
tortured by their passions
especially the passion for fame we are
so presumptuous that we want to be known
all over the world even by people who
will only come after we have gone and
perhaps the greatest source of suffering
is the most banal boredom we struggle
against obstacles but once they are
overcome rest proves intolerable because
of the boredom it produces Pascal's
bitter conclusion what is man are
nothing compared to the infinite Pascal
misses no opportunities to confront his
readers with evidence of mankind's
resolutely deviant pitiful and unworthy
nature in constantly seductive classical
French he informs us that happiness is
an illusion anyone who does not see the
vanity of the world is very vain himself
that misery is the norm if our condition
were truly happy we shouldn't need to
divert ourselves from thinking about it
the true love is a chimera how hollow
and foul is the heart of man that we are
as thin-skinned as we are vain a trifle
consoles us because of trifle upsets us
that even the strongest among us are
rendered helpless by the countless
diseases
to which we're vulnerable flies are so
mighty that they can paralyze our minds
and eat up our bodies that all worldly
institutions are corrupt
nothing is surer than that people will
be weak and finally that we are absurdly
prone to overestimate our own importance
how many kingdoms know nothing of us the
very best we may hope to do in these
circumstances Pascal suggests is to face
the desperate facts of our situation
head-on man's greatness comes from
knowing he is wretched given the tone it
comes as a real surprise to discover
that reading Pascal is not at all the
depressing experience one might have
presumed the work is consoling
heartwarming and even at times pretty
hilarious for those teetering on the
verge of despair there can paradoxically
be no finer book to turn to than one
which seeks to grind man's every last
hope into the dust the posse
far more than any saccharine volume
touting inner beauty positive thinking
or the realization of hidden potential
has the power to coax the suicidal of
the ledge of a high parapet if Pascal's
pessimism can so effectively console us
it's because we usually cast into gloom
not so much by negativity as by hope
it's hope with regard to our careers our
love lives our children our politicians
our planet that's primarily to blame for
angering and then embittering us the
incompatibility between the size of our
aspirations and the mean reality of our
condition generates the violent
disappointments which torture our days
and etch themselves in lines of acrimony
across our faces we should honor Pascal
and the long line of Christian
pessimists to which he belongs for doing
is the great favor of publicly and
elegantly rehearsing the facts of our
rather sinful and pitiful state reading
Pascal reminds us that the secular are
at this moment in history a great deal
more optimistic than the religious
something of an irony given the
frequency with which the latter have
been derided by the former for their
apparent naivety it's the secular whose
longing for perfection has grown so
intense as to lead them to imagine that
paradise might we realize on this earth
after just a few more years of financial
growth and medical research with no
evident awareness of the contradiction
they may in the same breath gruffly
dismiss a belief in angels while
sincerely trusting that the combined
powers of the IMF the Medical Research
Establishment Silicon Valley and
democratic politics will together cure
the ills of mankind religions have
wisely insisted that we are inherently
flawed creatures incapable of lasting
happiness beset by troubling desires
obsessed by status vulnerable to
appalling accidents and always heading
for death why should any of this be so
cheering perhaps because pessimistic
exaggeration is so comforting whatever
our private disappointments we can start
to feel very fortunate when we compare
our mood to pascals
Pascal wanted to turn us to God by
telling us how awful life was but by
sharing his pessimistic analyses he
ironically strengthens us to face the
trouble of our own lives
on this earth with greater courage
forbearance and occasional humor
you